I can't stand corruption I hate cronyism
and I really despise lies and it turns
out that Ivanka Trump is perpetrating
sort of all three at once she has a
position in the administration because
her dad is president she lied
that she would cut ties with the Trump
businesses to work for Trump and the
entire thing is completely corrupt
Ivanka Trump as you probably know has
been representing her dad has been
representing the administration has been
representing the United States at the
g20 overseas
she's been lobbying the Senate on tax
policy she's been doing all sorts of
political work and she is going to
continue earning about a million dollars
per year from the Trump businesses her
work as a representative of the
administration is relating directly to
her business earnings and McClatchy has
a really good piece on how this is all
just a horrifying and disgusting
conflict of interest because she's
continuing to make money developing from
the development of family business
resorts around the world and some of
those resorts hire state-owned companies
to do construction some of those resorts
get gifts from foreign governments
either in the form of eased regulations
for their resorts gifted land sometimes
payments from customers that are also
officials from those foreign countries
and in spirit she is completely guilty
of violating the emoluments Clause of
the Constitution that it's not just the
president that the emoluments Clause
applies to right all government
officials are barred from receiving any
gift of value from foreign governments
without the specific approval of
Congress but remember that there might
be a loophole legally here she doesn't
really have an official position in the
administration
she actually can't have one because of
nepotism laws laws that clearly are not
strict enough because she does have a
position in the administration by
everything other than name and salary so
let's get to some of the conflicts and
again McClatchy does a great job
reporting on this the Chinese government
has an
action company that they own which was
given a road building contract by Trump
Dubai huh it doesn't sound good
a local Indonesian government is going
to build a road to shorten the drive
between an airport and a Trump Resort
and Golf Course uh-oh that doesn't sound
good
a Saudi South Korean joint company will
build Trump's Lido City Indonesia result
well while we do a lot of political
dealings with Saudi Arabia nevermind
South Korea as well and number four you
probably know about theirs that Trump
International Hotel in DC which is
already being cited in multiple lawsuits
for emoluments Clause violations and we
heard straight up from foreign
dignitaries who said listen when we come
to the DC to do business we can stay at
the Four Seasons or at Trump's place
will stay at Trump's place to try to
ingratiate ourselves with him why not
now the Trump lawyers will try to defend
some of this stuff by saying listen just
because it has the Trump name on it
doesn't mean we're actually handing out
contracts a lot of times we just license
out the name whether that's true or not
in these particular cases Ivanka and her
siblings have been involved in these
projects and it leads to them making
money and I was thinking back as I was
researching this story yesterday
remember when Keith Olbermann was fired
from MSNBC for donating a few thousand
bucks to a political candidate it seems
like laughable peanuts compared to what
we have going on right now and it's
almost like if you elect the president
whose family is made up of the most
selfish and self-aggrandizing group of
people it doesn't end up being that good
for anybody but then and then remember
when Trump stood by those huge stacks of
paper with his lawyer and he made that
announcement that he's going to divest
and there's gonna be blind trust
remember how it was a huge show well it
just hasn't happened right it hasn't
happened the draining of the swamp
hasn't happened and we have no way of
really knowing what's going on with
Trump and Ivanka in detail because
there's no actual indication that
they're going to come clean or
Dress what's going on with those
supposed conflicts of interest they were
going to fix anytime soon
last thing by the way as far as Ivanka
goes we've now also learned that she's
working on one of those interim security
clearances it's believed that she's
having trouble getting a permanent
security clearance for the same reason
Jared Kushner is not getting one who's
her husband which is the complicated
financial situation involving foreign
contacts and foreign business this is a
national security risk and you know to
the audience I feel obligated to point
out this stuff is going on and the sad
part is more than likely nothing will
come of it but I still feel obligated to
tell you about it if you think that I
shouldn't even cover this stuff because
it's just an exercise in frustration let
me know but I I believe that it's
important to report on this type of
corruption and cronyism today's program
made possible in part by wink if I were
given the task of picking out a wine
that I was going to like with the catch
that it couldn't be a bottle of wine
that I had tried before I wouldn't know
where to start because I'm clueless
about wine
that's where wink comes in spell the
winc wink makes it easy to discover
great wines every month they ship you
wines that have been matched to your
taste and personalized to you through
what they call their palate profile quiz
so you can go to try wink comm slash
Pakman and again that's WI and see
you'll get asked just a few simple
questions how do you like your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and a few other questions and using
those answers the wink system will match
you to great wines you haven't tried
before personalized to you and delivered
right to your door as you drink more
wines and rate them yes or no yay or nay
I like or don't like
wink we'll learn and continue to send
you new personalized delicious wines for
the next month no membership fees you
can skip any delivery that you want
cancel anytime and wink has a 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you'll never
have to pay for a bottle you don't like
and for a limited time our viewers and
listeners can get $20 off
when you go to try wink calm slash
Pakman that's try wink spelled T ry winc
comm /p a km a n for $20 off that's try
wink comm slash Pakman